ENRICO BIANCO: Thank you,
everybody who has shown up here
in person and everybody who's
tuning in on the live stream.
My name is Enrico
Bianco, and I serve
as the neurodiversity at work
lead for Special Needs Network.
For those of you
who aren't familiar,
Special Needs Network is a
company-wide employee resource
group.
We're about 800 strong by
the Google group numbers,
and we cover a wide
range of topics.
If you identify as
somebody with special needs
or as neurodiverse, or if
you have a friend, relative,
or somebody else
who you are caring
for who falls into
that category,
or if you are simply interested
in knowing more about how
to be an ally and improving
things within the company,
we are your group.
And this is one of
a number of talks
that we have had in our Special
Needs Network speaker series.
And we're really excited
to host this talk today.
So when Florida Frenz
was a young girl,
she decided that she
wanted to write a book.
And she compiled her
experiences growing up
autistic and her
artwork into a book
called "How to Be Human-- the
Diary of an Autistic Girl."
And now, she is stepping
out from behind her pen name
to readdress the world
as herself, Georgia Lyon.
And so, on behalf of Google
and the Special Needs Network,
please join me in
welcoming Georgia Lyon.
[APPLAUSE]
ENRICO BIANCO: So to
start off, what motivated
you to write "How to be Human"?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, I had always
had a dream of writing a book,
ever since I read "Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone"
at age seven.
ENRICO BIANCO: [LAUGHING]
GEORGIA LYON: So I would
say the biggest motivation
for me was just I really wanted
to get that life goal done.
But I think, as I
was writing the book,
I sort of realized, hey,
my life could actually
help other people.
The things I've been
through could actually
help a lot of other people,
too, in ways that I had never
really thought about before.
I'd only really thought about
my individual experiences
with autism.
But I'd never seen
how it could tie
to other people
and the collective,
I guess, autistic
experience as a whole.
So through writing
the book, I saw that.
And I think, once I actually
had the book published,
I was, like, well, that
was actually a good reason
to write the book, too, not
just for myself, but for others.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And how did you come up with
the pen name, Florida Frenz?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, I guess
Florida came from the fact
that my first name is Georgia.
So I just thought of
it as being in, like,
a different state of mind.
And that pun was totally
intended, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
GEORGIA LYON: And then
Frenz I just chose
because it's
spelled differently.
But it's a pun off of the
word, like, "friends" plural.
Because so much of the
book is about emotions
and social skills and the stuff
you would need to make friends.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And so you wrote that book
when you were how old?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, I wrote
it officially when I was 15.
But a lot of the artwork, I
did back when I was eight.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
So that was at 15.
And now, as a
young adult, you're
stepping out from behind
that pen name, Florida Frenz,
and reintroducing yourself to
the world under your real name.
Can you tell us a bit about
what inspired you to do that?
GEORGIA LYON: The only reason
I really had the pen name
originally was because
I wanted some privacy
while I finished high school.
As you probably know,
high school around here
is very rigorous, and I
needed a lot of energy
to be able to focus
on my academics
and learn as best I could.
And I felt that if people knew
I'd published a book, well,
first of all, I would just get
a lot of attention for that.
Second of all, I wasn't
sure if that attention
would be completely
positive, knowing
how kind of immature
high schoolers can be.
So when I published
the book, of course,
all my classmates were 15, too.
So it's not exactly
the best age.
But I guess what's
motivated me to step out
now is that, obviously,
I've graduated high school.
I'm about to go on to college.
I don't care as much if people
know private information
about my personal experiences
or if they judge it.
Because I figure if they
have time to judge me,
then they probably should
be doing other things
with their life.
And, you know, it is what it is.
ENRICO BIANCO: That is a
good philosophy, definitely.
So when and how did you
learn that you were autistic?
GEORGIA LYON: I
learned at age seven,
when I was watching this
show called "Dogs with Jobs."
It featured dogs helping
people with various things,
you know, search and rescue
dogs, dogs for the blind.
And one episode
featured a dog who
was helping a boy with autism.
And I looked at that boy.
And in many ways, he
was different from me.
But I noticed one
similarity, which
was that when he got excited,
he flapped his hands like I
did when I was excited.
And after watching the
show, I was eating a snack.
And I just kind of
casually asked my mom.
I was like, Mom,
do I have autism?
And there was just
sort of this pause.
And then, a little surprised,
she said, yeah, you do.
And that was a bit of a,
I guess, shock for me.
I mean, I had always kind
of sensed I was different.
In some ways, it eventually
was a step forward.
But, I think, at first, it
was kind of a step back,
because I wondered
if she hadn't told me
because there was something
seriously wrong with me.
So that was not a good
feeling to have initially
upon finding out I had autism.
ENRICO BIANCO: But
further to that,
actually, how did learning
that you are autistic
sort of affect the way that
you thought about yourself
and others at that time?
GEORGIA LYON: I
think, at that time,
it made me feel like I was
somehow lesser than others,
or others couldn't
really like me
because I had some, like,
weird disability or disease.
And, you know, when
you're seven or eight,
you do want to be
like everyone else.
ENRICO BIANCO: Um, hm.
GEORGIA LYON: So
that made it hard.
But, I think, over
time, I sort of
realized that I do
have challenges,
but other people do, as well.
And while they may face
different challenges,
just the fact that everyone
struggles with something
is sort of something
that connects me
with the rest of humanity.
So, I think, over time,
it allowed me to actually
empathize with people more.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And speaking of challenges,
what do you think
were the most
significant challenges
that you faced
growing up autistic?
GEORGIA LYON: Understanding my
own emotions was definitely one
and understanding the
emotions of other people.
If you can't do
that, man, the world
is a really scary
and confusing place.
But I guess what
helped me with that
was just I did a lot
of artwork with Shelah.
She is in the room-- but, yeah--
back there in the nice red tank
top.
And I think doing that
artwork kind of allowed
me to slow down the whole
process of social interactions.
Because usually they
happen very quickly.
It's sort of lightning fast.
You have to be able to read many
small cues, micro expressions,
et cetera.
But when I was
doing art, I could
have time to kind of look
at what I was creating,
really think about it,
attach something tangible
to what otherwise might be
abstract and chaotic thoughts.
And through that
process, I learned
how to understand emotions.
And once I understood
my own emotions,
it was much easier for
me to feel in control
and have enough,
I guess, bandwidth
in my brain to try to understand
the emotions of other people,
too.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's really
fascinating, actually.
So how did you pick up or
learn your social skills?
What methods did you
find worked best for you?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, as I already
said, a lot of drawing and just
talking about social situations
with either my therapists
or, once I was a little
bit more advanced
with my social skills, the
friends that I managed to make.
ENRICO BIANCO: Hm.
GEORGIA LYON: But I really
wish there was a better way
to say this.
I think there's just a lot
of trial and error, you know.
For those of you
have read "Outliers,"
Malcolm Gladwell
says that if you
want to become an
expert in something,
you need 10,000 hours of
just brute-force practice.
Well, that's the
best way to learn
how to pass as a
neurotypical, is just
brute-force practice,
lots of trial and error,
and some rather
embarrassing moments.
[LAUGHTER]
ENRICO BIANCO: I
wonder how many hours
you have accumulated
over all, then,
in deliberate practice
at being social.
I think that number
might be a little bit
staggering for myself, too.
So as a teenager,
how open were you
with others about
being autistic?
GEORGIA LYON: I was pretty
open with my friends, honestly,
my close friends at least.
With just casual acquaintances,
maybe not as much, and not
always as open with
my teachers, but I
think I was open with the
people I really cared about
and who I felt would
just like me for me.
And then, for people I wasn't as
sure of whether they would just
like me for me or how they
would view me, I wasn't as open.
But I never exactly hid it.
It just wasn't something
I would publicly declare.
Like, I wouldn't just run into
a room and shout, hey, everyone,
I'm autistic, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
GEORGIA LYON: But,
I mean, if they
saw me flapping and figured
it out, I really didn't care.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And what are your thoughts
on disclosure now, actually?
GEORGIA LYON: I think it's
a very nuanced subject,
to be perfectly honest.
I don't think there is one
formula for when to disclose
or how to disclose.
You kind of have to just go by
what you feel comfortable with.
And I think, within
the autistic community,
some people will feel more
comfortable disclosing
about their autism than others.
Personally, I generally, as I
said, disclose to my friends,
whatever acquaintances I feel
comfortable with, my teachers,
sometimes, if I
feel comfortable.
But, you know, I don't think
there is a one-size-fit-all
model for disclosing.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's very true.
I have found that to be
true of myself, as well.
Sometimes it's just something
you have to figure out
on a case-by-case basis.
So what challenges would you
say that you face presently
because of autism?
GEORGIA LYON: For
me personally, it's
mostly the sensory
overload aspect of it now.
I feel, in general, that I can
read social cues a lot better
than when I was younger.
But it gets very hard when
there's a lot going on
in the environment.
And especially in
noisy environments,
I seem to have more
sound sensitivities
than I think a lot
of people who are,
quote unquote, "this high
functioning" on the spectrum.
But I think, yeah, that's
the main part, just going
into a new environment, almost
having this physical need
to, like, look at everything
in there and just take it in
before I can even really
interact with people
or fully enjoy myself, just
the constant stress of always
having background noises, like
voices, doors closing, fans.
I'm just using various
examples of noises
I actually hear in this
room, which is fairly quiet.
But, you know, obviously,
in other environments,
like in high school,
oh, man, there
was just constant chatter,
even during tests and stuff.
So that was rough.
ENRICO BIANCO: I can sort
of identify with that.
The one that I'm really
noticing right now
is the way that
the room is lit--
GEORGIA LYON: Oh, yeah.
ENRICO BIANCO: --the
lights overhead as well as
the sunlight coming
in from the window.
So, yeah, I don't
think that I have
maybe all of the sensory
integration issues.
It's very different
for everyone.
But it's definitely noticeable.
What advantages would you
say that an autistic mind
has afforded you?
GEORGIA LYON: I think it's
afforded me the ability
to be a bit more rational.
So for example, back
in middle school,
when most people are catapulting
between extreme highs and lows
emotionally, I was able to
kind of stabilize myself
by thinking of life this way.
So if I had a day, and some
good stuff had happened
and some bad stuff had
happened, I'd be like,
well, this part of the day
was good, this part of the day
was bad.
If I average the two,
it's an average day.
And just kind of move on
with life, instead of getting
caught up in the emotional
back and forth of everything.
And then, I think,
another big one
has been it's allowed me
to have very strong morals.
Because I'm sure
many of you have
heard that autistic people are
very black and white thinkers.
And I think, when it
comes to sort of ideals,
that can be a good thing.
Because I know it allows
me to be a loyal friend.
Because there's just
some rules that I
follow when I'm with my friends,
that just mean that, you know,
I'm just kind to them
when I'm around them
or try to be the
best friend I can be.
I try not to get caught up
in, like, the social drama
or project my own emotional
turmoil onto them,
unlike some people
do, unfortunately.
And I think it's allowed me to
be a strong student, as well.
Because generally, I'm
very honest with my work,
and I don't plagiarize
or cheat or do stuff
like that, so strong morals.
And then I think the final
one, which many people
seem to think is actually a
deficit in autism, is empathy.
I really think that
having autism and having
the experiences
I've had has allowed
me to be much more
empathetic towards people
who are just outsiders in
any way, shape, or form.
Like, I just remember, during
my middle school days or even
my early high school days, if
I was talking with someone,
and we were hitting it off and
everything was going great,
but a third person
came up and was sort
of awkwardly hanging on
the outside of the group,
not sure what to do, I would
always be the one who'd be,
like, so what do you
think of this or that?
And I would kind of bring
them into the group,
because I just remember so
much as a young child, when
I was, like, six or
seven, I would always
be the one who was
hanging on the outside.
And I just knew how bad
that felt. So I just
wanted to give them
a leg up if I could.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's a
really interesting point.
Because there's sort of this
meme that autistics do not have
or cannot express empathy,
coming from the theory of mind
research from Simon Baron-Cohen
as well as other stuff that
derived from that.
Could you say a little bit
more about that, actually,
like, how do you feel
about that statement,
that autistics do
not have empathy?
Do you think that's true?
GEORGIA LYON: I really do
not think that's true at all.
I think that many autistic
people are actually
very empathetic.
And the main problem
is not so much
that they lack certain neurons
or certain ways of thinking
as much as, actually, those
neurons or ways of thinking
are hyperactive.
So it causes a state where
the person just shuts down,
because they're so overwhelmed
by sensory input or emotions
that they just can't
express it in the ways
that most people would think
of as being empathetic.
But, I think, really,
when you're inside of it,
when you feel
what's going on, you
realize that you feel
other people's emotions
and that they are affecting you.
You just can't convey that well.
I just remember, as
a kid, sometimes,
I would almost be like
an aerial for emotions,
where if I would go to,
like, the class, for example,
and everyone there
was feeling tired,
even if I entered the classroom
feeling energetic, by the time
I left, I would
feel tired or sad
or whatever other
people were feeling.
So, no, I don't think it's true.
I think it's almost
the opposite,
where you have to
learn how to, like,
separate yourself from others
sometimes in order to function.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And there is something to that,
the so-called overwhelming
world theory.
So in your book, you
describe yourself
as an empowered autistic.
For those that haven't had
a chance to read the book,
tell us a bit more
about what that means.
GEORGIA LYON: To
me, what it means
is that, while you
have autism, you
can still lead a very
successful, fulfilling life
just as you are.
You don't need to change
anything about yourself
or the way you think.
And, you know, obviously,
there may be some areas where
life will be a little
bit more difficult.
But you'll also have the
ability to see things
in a unique way that will add
a lot of richness and depth
to your life, if you're
an empowered autistic,
I think, and share that with
the rest of the world, as well.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And what advice would
you offer to autistics
that want to empower
themselves or their allies?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, to autistics
who want to empower themselves,
I would say, I
think, be flexible.
I know this is not
something a lot of people
necessarily say in the
neurodiversity movement.
But just learning how to
think like a neurotypical
can actually be really useful.
I think that some
autistic people
are afraid that if they learn
too much about neurotypicals,
if they, you know, do,
quote unquote, "therapy,"
that they will somehow lose the
autistic aspects of themselves.
And I don't think that's true.
I think it's just
simply opening your mind
to a new way of
thinking, not necessarily
a better way of
thinking, just a new one.
And it'll give you more
options for how you think.
The way I like to
describe it to people
is it's like learning
a second language.
You don't forget
your first language.
You just have a
greater vocabulary now
to speak with more people.
And so I think that
autistic people
should be open to learning how
to think like neurotypicals,
learning about
certain forms of body
language, facial
expressions, and whatnot.
And, I think, in
terms of allies,
I think the allies,
too, have to be
flexible but in a different way.
They have to have
the flexibility
to let autistic
people direct them.
Because some autistic people
will want to learn more about
neurotypicals.
And some will just want to
be themselves as they are.
And I think that if an autistic
person expresses the desire
to learn more about
neurotypicals,
their allies should
help them do so.
But if they just want
to be as they are now,
their allies should also respect
that wish and let them do so.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's really
fascinating, actually,
and kind of uncanny.
Because I know that I've
described being autistic
internally as being
sort of like a learner
of a foreign language.
And a good friend
of mine actually
put it really well when he
said that being autistic
is like being a foreigner
in every culture.
And it really feels like
it's true sometimes.
Speaking of that,
actually, how does it
feel to interact with
other autistics, as opposed
to interacting with the
neurologically typical?
GEORGIA LYON: I notice
slight differences.
But to be perfectly
honest, I think
there are more similarities.
I don't actually notice
a lot of differences.
I notice, when I'm interacting
with autistic people,
there can be slightly
less eye contact.
Or sometimes, they'll
have their stims,
you know, rocking in a
chair or flapping a bit.
But, honestly, I feel
like there is just
a lot of diversity in the
neurotypical community,
too, more than most
people, I think, realize.
And there is also
a lot of diversity
on the autism spectrum.
So really, when it
comes down to it,
the interactions are more
determined by the individual
than their diagnosis.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
And what, I don't know if
I would call them coping
mechanisms or
adaptations, have you
learned to make when interacting
with the neurologically
typical?
GEORGIA LYON:
Personally, for me, I
have my hand grabbing-- I guess,
you can't really see it here,
but I kind of often go like
this in class or wherever--
to stop myself from
flapping, because that helps.
Because sometimes I don't want
to be flapping everywhere.
Or I kind of have learned
to very consciously make
eye contact with people.
Like right now, for
example, I'm not
doing the typical stage
thing, where you just
look at the back
curtain and you pretend
that you're making eye
contact with everyone
by secretly looking over them.
I'm actually kind of looking
at everyone in the audience.
And then, I think,
the other big one
is just that, if I'm
not sure, I observe
before I enter a situation.
ENRICO BIANCO: I think that's
actually pretty interesting.
Because I remember, I was
talking with another autistic.
And she looked at me.
And she said, do you think that
I'm looking you in the eyes?
And I said, I think so.
I think that's eye contact.
And she said, actually,
I'm looking right here,
is what she told me.
And this was her mechanism for
giving eye contact, or at least
the perception of it, but
without becoming overwhelmed.
GEORGIA LYON: Well,
personally, for me, I actually
do give eye contact.
Because with my
other sensory issues,
I actually find
that it helps me.
So if I can't hear someone,
looking at their face
and just seeing how
their mouth moves
can actually be very useful.
So I think that a
lot of my teachers
think that I'm really just
paying very attentive attention
in class, when really I just
want to hear what they're
saying, like everyone else.
But everyone else can kind
of look away and be, like,
whereas I have to actually
look at them in order
to kind of understand
what they're
saying with my sensory issues.
ENRICO BIANCO: So
in her TED Talk,
actually, or in a
number of her talks,
Temple Grandin talks about
different types of thinkers
on the autism spectrum.
She herself identifies
as a visual thinker.
As she puts it, she has
Google for Images in her head.
GEORGIA LYON: Um, hm.
ENRICO BIANCO: She also talks
about the math and language
types, who are really good
at perceiving patterns.
Where do you think you fall
within those classifications?
GEORGIA LYON: You know,
it's really interesting.
Because, I think,
when I was younger,
I fell in more with
the visual thinkers.
But around age seven or eight,
I actually did a lot of therapy,
because I was having a lot of
issues learning how to read.
So I think, through all
that intensive therapy,
I really developed a lot
of strong neural networks
for language thinking, too.
So now, I don't think I
neatly fit into either box.
I'm sort of a
mumbo-jumbo of both.
ENRICO BIANCO:
That's interesting.
Because I was going to
ask, actually, if you had
noticed your ways of thinking
changing over the years.
Have you?
GEORGIA LYON: Yeah, I
think I've definitely
become a bit more of a language
thinker over the years.
I never quite got into the
whole mathematic thing.
Like, math still doesn't really
work with my brain in general.
But I definitely have become
much stronger with language,
a little bit less strong
in terms of visual skills,
though I still have
decent ones, I'd say.
ENRICO BIANCO: So your
book, "How to be Human,"
it's not just a simple diary.
It also includes your artwork.
Tell us a bit more
about that artwork.
What does that mean to you?
And what meaning does it hold?
And how does it fit into the
subject matter of the book?
GEORGIA LYON: The
artwork in that book
was a lot of the
artwork I originally
did to understand social
skills and my own emotions.
So it's just very
valuable to me,
because that was really when
I had my big breakthrough.
I feel like before that
I'd been sort of isolated
in my own kind of
glass ball of autism.
And that artwork was
really the pickax
which allowed me to
kind of break out.
Yeah, that's basically the
meaning it holds to me and why.
That was why it was so
helpful and whatnot.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's
really fascinating.
Actually, I'd love it
if you could elaborate
a little bit more on that.
In what ways did your art help
you to sort of learn to, quote,
"be human"?
GEORGIA LYON: I
think it helped me,
as I've said before, because it
allowed me to slow everything
down and kind of take
it at my own pace,
instead of having to be
thrown into the middle
of a social interaction
that was too complex for me
to understand while it
was going lightning fast.
But I think it also just
allowed me to get more in touch
with my own emotions, too, and
kind of see that I had them
and that I could
understand them,
as opposed to it
just being something
that was foreign and complex.
ENRICO BIANCO: And do
you still draw today?
GEORGIA LYON: I draw a lot less
than I used to, I must admit.
Generally, I write more.
ENRICO BIANCO: So
in what ways do you
feel you express yourself now?
GEORGIA LYON: I express
myself much more
verbally, I would say, whether
it's through my writing
or talking with my friends.
I mean, I do still like to draw.
But unfortunately,
I do not generally
make as much time
for it as I should.
So if I do need
to express myself,
it generally is with words,
now that I have a stronger
understanding of
what words I can
use to actualize my emotional
vocabulary, shall we say.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
Tell us a little bit more
about that, actually.
Like, how did the
writing and the drawing
help you to sort of navigate
your own emotional state?
GEORGIA LYON: I think, as
I said before, it allowed
me to express kind of abstract
thoughts in concrete ways,
especially the drawing aspect.
And then, in terms of
just writing the book,
I think that allowed me to
really think about my life's
experiences as a whole and see a
way to define autism for myself
more.
Because, as probably
many of you know,
certainly, there
is a DSM-- I don't
know-- -5 definition for
autism, the diagnostic criteria,
whatever that is.
And while I think it helps
to create groups and then
deliver some help
to those groups,
it doesn't allow for much,
kind of, individual depth.
It doesn't really have
the human aspect to it.
So I think writing
my book allowed
me to see the human aspect
in autism more in myself
and then later on for others.
ENRICO BIANCO: Right.
So "How to be Human" is, in a
way, a children's book, right?
But do you expect that
there's something to take away
from the book for
an adult audience,
like, say, the one that we
have here for this talk?
GEORGIA LYON: Oh, definitely.
I think the takeaway
for pretty much everyone
is that we're all
different, and we all kind
of struggle in different areas.
But, fundamentally, that's
part of what makes us human,
and we shouldn't
be ashamed of that.
And we should help
each other with it
and learn from each other's
experiences, instead of,
I guess, shutting
each other down.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's
very much true, actually.
Do feel that you still have
difficulty making and keeping
friendships and professional
networking relationships
and things like that?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, I don't do
much professional networking
at 18.
But, yeah.
ENRICO BIANCO: It's never
too late or early to start.
[LAUGHTER]
GEORGIA LYON: Certainly.
But, no, I don't.
I think now I
actually have a lot
of long-lasting friendships,
the longest of which
is my friend who I've been
friends with for 15 years now.
So, no, I really don't.
In fact, I'd say I just
have more difficulty making
new friends.
Because, generally,
in new situations,
there is a lot of more
sensory information to take in
and a lot more to learn.
So that's still where I
kind of struggle the most.
But in terms of
maintaining, once I've
learned how to recognize facial
patterns and certain body
language things in a person,
I'm pretty good at figuring out
what the person is feeling and
maintaining their friendship
if I care to do so.
ENRICO BIANCO: And tell us
a bit more about yourself.
Like, what do you like
to do with your leisure
time, hobbies, and so on?
GEORGIA LYON: Well,
I like martial arts.
I did tae kwon do for
about seven years.
AUDIENCE: Woo-hoo!
[LAUGHTER]
ENRICO BIANCO: [LAUGHTER]
I'd say we've got a fan.
GEORGIA LYON: Woo!
Those who kick together
stick together.
[LAUGHTER]
ENRICO BIANCO: I didn't
know that was a saying.
That's really cool.
GEORGIA LYON: Well, it is.
But now, let's see.
Now, I'm doing karate, though,
just for a change of pace.
And that's also really fun.
I like swimming, as well,
just kind of casual swimming.
I started that when I was three.
Because, apparently,
I jumped into a pool
before I knew how to swim.
And my parents can give you the
full story if you wished here.
But then I also
like to read a lot.
And, let's see,
what other things?
Yeah, and social, I
guess, justice issues
are really interesting
to me at the moment,
as well, just everything
from neurodiversity,
to women's issues,
to issues including
racial minorities, the LGBTQ
community, all of that stuff.
ENRICO BIANCO: So what else do
you do in the area of advocacy
for autism or for other related
social justice or disability
issues?
GEORGIA LYON: So while I
was still in high school,
during my final semester
there, my school
founded this club called the
PSA, which was the Pinewood
Social Awareness club.
And I did a lot of
advocacy with them.
And we had an assembly
just to generally educate
on learning differences
and racial issues
and women's issues and a lot
of other issues, as well.
I also just do a
lot of interviews
to help advocate for autism
and autism awareness.
And, yeah, I would say
that's about it so far.
But I hope to do
more in the future.
ENRICO BIANCO: And
who would you say
are your biggest influences?
GEORGIA LYON: I would say
probably my family and friends,
so my parents, the
people I've known
for many years such as Shelah
and my other autism therapists,
and just many of the wonderful
friends I've made along the way
through high school and whatnot.
ENRICO BIANCO: And
anybody within, say,
the wider autism community,
authors, people who've spoken?
GEORGIA LYON: I
really like Carly,
if you've ever had a chance
to see any of her videos.
She I think was originally
diagnosed as being,
quote unquote,
"low functioning."
But, it turned
out, she really did
have a very great understanding
of the world and much depth
to her thoughts.
And she has this wonderful video
called "Carly's Cafe," which
I think explains sensory
overload basically better
than anything I've ever seen.
And she is a wonderful
person, I think,
that I like to
model myself off of.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's a
really good video, actually.
And I have read "Carly's
Voice," and I highly
recommend it to everyone here.
I think there's a lot of,
maybe, controversy around Carly,
some people who may be on
the fence about whether they
believe that she is
actually expressing herself
through her writing.
But I think that if you
look past all of that
and just let what she's
saying-- in her posts,
in her book, in her
videos-- speak for itself,
it says a lot about the
experience of being autistic.
So do you still write?
Are you maybe thinking
of writing another book?
GEORGIA LYON: Yes,
though I think
it will be in a different
genre this time.
I'm thinking of entering into
fiction and kind of exploring
some other writing
ideas I've had.
I don't know necessarily
if I'll write
another book about my
life anytime soon, though.
ENRICO BIANCO: I
was wondering if you
have any advice for autistics
in the workplace who
may be having trouble fitting
in with their working group
or having issues
with their manager.
How would you advise that those
people advocate for themselves
and get those problems solved?
GEORGIA LYON: Well, I would say
that, if they are in a position
to do so, should be honest about
having autism, first of all.
I think that that shows
management and other employees
that you are confident
and self-aware, which
are very attractive qualities
to most employers, I would say.
And I think that
they just need to let
other people know when something
is not going their way.
They don't have to
necessarily be rude about it.
interrupt what's going on.
But just later talking
with their manager
or other employees
to try to come up
with strategies to cope
better in the future,
or even just having the
ability to maybe break
for five minutes
in a quiet space
where they can decompress, I
think would be very helpful.
And then, in terms of
the other employees,
I think that they
just need to be very
clear about what they're doing.
They need to make sure that
they have clearly set guidelines
and expectations.
Because I can say personally,
from my experiences,
that autistics are not very good
at determining what you want
from very murky instructions.
I know that it's a
struggle for everyone.
But I think it's more so
for people on the spectrum.
ENRICO BIANCO:
It's kind of funny,
because navigating
ambiguity is actually, like,
part of our job description as
software engineers at Google.
And it feels weird
sometimes, like being
expected to do something that
I know that we're so weak at.
But we try our best, right?
GEORGIA LYON: Indeed.
I mean, I don't think
that navigating ambiguity
is necessarily a
strength for anyone.
It's just more difficult for
those of us on the spectrum.
So definitely, I think
that's one of the issues
that people who are neurotypical
can relate to the most,
I think.
ENRICO BIANCO:
That's a true point.
GEORGIA LYON: Yeah.
And then I think the other
big thing for employees
is just, yeah, to
be very flexible
and be willing to listen.
Because, I think, when
you're in a majority,
such as the
neurotypical majority,
you kind of think everyone
else thinks like you.
And that's not always true.
And it's sometimes hard to
imagine anything different.
But I think you just have to
be open-minded about that.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's
all really, really good.
Thank you.
That's actually a lot of
stuff for me to think about,
as I continue to advise
the Special Needs Network
and the company as a
whole in neurodiversity
in the workplace.
And with that, I've definitely
run to the end of the questions
that I had.
And so if anybody
in the audience
has questions for
Georgia, I believe
we have a mic up
on the podium here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming and talking
about your experiences.
Any advice for parents
of autistic children?
GEORGIA LYON: Oh, I guess
my advice to parents
would be the same advice as I
gave to just allies in general,
which is just to kind of
be flexible and see what
your child wants and needs.
I think, don't be
afraid, though,
to do what you think is
right for your child also
is a big one.
Because I think
some parents feel
as if they have to
follow what other doctors
or therapists say.
Because those are the, quote
unquote, "professionals."
But, probably, you
know your child
better than any
professional really
can with just X number
of hours of assessment.
So you have to do what
you feel, I think,
is right, in many cases.
Because while their
people are trying to help,
they just don't have
the same understanding
of your life and your
child's life that you do.
ENRICO BIANCO: So building on
that a little bit, in what ways
did your parents support
you as you were growing up?
GEORGIA LYON: I know they
were very important in helping
to find the
therapists that I have
or have had throughout my life.
For example, I know we started
with some just general kind
of social skills therapists.
They weren't
necessarily hurting me,
but they weren't
necessarily helping
me develop my social
skills any further.
So after a couple
months, they just
changed course, even though
those therapists were
from some program that did
ABA, which was considered
the mainstream at
the time and, I
think, actually still is
considered the mainstream
treatment for autism.
But instead, my parents
switched over to Shelah
and another therapist
named Sarah, who did not
do as many mainstream things.
They did more kind of
Greenspan and play time,
which was actually
more beneficial for me
because it was more dynamic
and more about being
flexible and learning
patterns in social situations
quickly and learning how to kind
of be creative along with it
and play pretend.
So I think that
was very important.
ENRICO BIANCO: Something
like social role-play--
GEORGIA LYON: Yes.
ENRICO BIANCO: --or guidance
in social situations?
Yeah, I remember there
was something like that
when I was a child, as well.
My mother put me
into this program
that brought children together.
And we either role-played
social situations,
or we just had guidance when
interacting with each other,
as to how to, I guess, socialize
better with each other.
And that was really actually
valuable for me growing up.
AUDIENCE: You spoke a
lot about things outside
of your education that
have really helped you,
things like artwork
and some special people
in your lives, your parents
being so supportive.
But I was wondering
about successes
that you have had
in the classroom,
specifically with teachers
or maybe programs at school.
I'm nor sure specifically
where you go to school.
But are their things,
like programs,
that have helped you grow
as an individual or just
through education?
GEORGIA LYON: You know,
that's honestly hard to say.
I was homeschooled from
first grade to seventh grade.
So I would say that's why
a lot of my experiences
came from sort of outside an
established school program.
Because we sort of created
our own school curriculum
during those years.
And then, by the time I
went back to kind of, right,
more of a regular form of
school in eighth grade,
my autism, while still
there, wasn't preventing me
from learning in the same
way as it had in the past,
so I didn't
necessarily participate
in a lot of special
programs or even
get accommodations in middle
school or high school.
So I don't honestly know.
But in terms of successes I've
had just inside the classroom,
I would say, I generally made
As in most of my high school
classes.
I took some AP courses
and did pretty well
on the AP tests in general.
And I got along well with
most of my teachers, I think.
I can't actually think of
any teachers that hated me
in high school, so that's
probably an achievement
in and of itself.
ENRICO BIANCO: That's
definitely a positive.
And were group projects
a lot of a problem?
GEORGIA LYON:
Group projects were
kind of a logistical
problem, but not so much
with the social skills.
It was just basically
that I define hell
as coordinating more than
two people's schedules to get
together at the same time.
But the social skills
part was actually fine .
I'd say, in fact, in some
of my group projects,
that I was more socially
and emotionally mature
than other people in them.
So it was mostly just
about not getting caught up
in whatever their drama
was when such issues arose.
AUDIENCE: As a quick
extension, so a lot of us--
I'd say all of us in this room--
went to school a while ago,
right?
We were in high school, you
know, decades potentially ago,
depending on who you talk to.
But I was wondering if you think
that, in the event that you
do need accommodations, or
maybe friends of yours that
do need accommodations,
do you think that you
have everything you need?
I think a lot of
us probably felt
that we didn't always have the
accommodations that we wanted.
And I was just kind of wondering
about the way schools work now.
GEORGIA LYON: You
know, there are still
definitely issues with that.
I mean, I can say, I know,
actually, you're right.
I do have friends who
have accommodations.
One of my closest friends
in high school did.
And, you know, I'd say
overall it was OK for her.
But there were some kind of
hiccups or awkward moments.
Like I know, for example,
on some standardized tests,
they don't give you
necessarily breaks
if you have accommodations.
So you have to really know
how to pace your own time.
And often people don't,
so they can end up
with kind of awkward
amounts of time.
Like they'll take 20 minutes on
one section of, like, the ACT.
And then they wind
up with an hour
at the end of the whole thing.
And they're like, well,
now I have an hour
to do a section that's
really only going
to take me like 25 minutes.
So there's hiccups like that.
Or there's just people
who don't, I guess,
understand accommodations.
You know, some people
still definitely think
that, if you get accommodations,
you're just getting a leg up
on everyone else.
And so they'll put
you down for that.
Or, you know,
teachers won't really
follow the accommodations
they're supposed to give.
So, I mean, I think it's
heading in the right direction.
But there's definitely still
some progress to be made.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So do you feel that today,
your autism, because of it,
do you view things or people
or events in the world
differently from other people?
GEORGIA LYON: I think sometimes
yes, but sometimes no.
I don't know.
It's very hard to say.
As I said before,
I think there's
a lot of kind of
diversity amongst people
who aren't autistic.
Because even if they're
not neurotypical,
they could still have other
so-called differences,
ADHD, emotional
disorders, et cetera.
So it's hard to say, I think.
In general, I view things in
the same way as a lot of people
my age kind of or who have
gone through similar life's
experiences.
But I think the big one
still for me is just
sensory processing.
That's really where I think
different in the way I perceive
the world from a lot of
people, especially when it
comes coughing.
That's one sound that really
drives me absolutely nuts.
So I think, you know, most
people, if they enter a room
and there's someone
coughing, they don't care.
And for me, I'm
just, like, can I
get out of here as soon
as possible, please?
And I'll try to, kind
of, do so if I can.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any advice for someone
who's making, say,
online products that
could make it easier for an
autistic person to access?
Because around
here, we're big fans
of making information
universally
accessible and useful.
GEORGIA LYON: Oh, gosh.
I don't really know, honestly.
I mean, I think that a
lot of autistic people
are quite savvy on the internet,
to be perfectly honest,
not to buy into the nerdy
engineer stereotype too much.
But I think that's definitely
a large portion of those who
are on the autistic spectrum.
And so, I mean, I
think probably if they
want the resource, they
already know how to find it,
would be my big piece
of advice on that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for talking today.
It's been really,
really wonderful
to hear your insights.
I wondered if you had
anything to say to how society
as a whole views autism?
So, of course,
recently it's been
something that's been very
much talked about and not
just in the research
community and in society
in general in an innocent way.
But there have been parents
who have been not vaccinating
their kids because they
think that this is how
I am going to give them autism.
There have been a lot of
similar paranoias and scares.
And what would you say to
put people on a better path,
I guess?
GEORGIA LYON: I
guess what I would
say to that is I want them
to realize that autism is not
a tragedy in and of itself.
I think, for many
people, it really
is just a different way of
thinking about the world.
Well, one thing
I've noticed, too,
just in society in
general, is there
seems to be this
idea that if you
have autism that you're going
to be kind of extremely smart
but lacking in
empathy and unable
to really socialize or want
to be with other people.
And I think people have to stop
perpetuating that stereotype.
It is really just not true.
I've seen it in so many
movies, so many TV shows.
And I think it's starting to
really stick in people's minds,
just outside of the scientific
community or the community
of people who actually
know people with autism.
And it's something I really
try to speak out against,
for example, with movies
such as-- oh, what
was it-- "The Imitation Game"
I thought kind of perpetuated
that stereotype a lot and
kind of got on my nerves.
But, I think, what
society in general
has to realize is that
there is a lot more
diversity on the autism
spectrum than anyone can really
describe, I think.
Because each individual has
a very unique experience
with autism.
There's no one-size-fits-all
for autism.
I mean, I just know,
even talking with Enrico,
even though we're both fairly
similar in our experiences,
we definitely have areas
where we are different.
Like I have definitely more
sensory processing problems
it seems than he does.
Or, for example,
earlier, when we
were talking about
various sensory things,
I noticed all the sounds.
But he was the one who noticed
the lights, which I didn't even
notice.
So I think people
have to realize
that autistic
people aren't always
the scientists kind of huddled
at the edge of the room.
In fact, for me,
I would actually
say math and science
are kind of hard
and that verbal stuff is easier.
So I think that autistic
people themselves
have to be allowed to speak
more to their experiences.
And I guess those
should be considered
more valuable than whatever
movies portray autism
as being in general.
ENRICO BIANCO: But expanding
on the portrayal of autism
in the media, would
you say that there
are any examples, you can
think of, of doing it right?
GEORGIA LYON: I would say so.
I mean, I think one movie I
saw that did it really well was
"Temple," which was based
off of Temple Grandin's life
experiences when
she was younger.
And, I mean, I
think in that case,
it really showed her
with a lot of compassion.
And it showed, definitely,
the challenges she faced.
It didn't try to downplay those.
But it showed, too,
how she was really
able to make very unique
contributions to the world,
not just because
she was autistic
but because she had this very
special passion for helping
animals, as well.
And I think another example
I've seen-- it's fictional,
but I think it's well done--
is "The Curious Incident
of the Dog in the Night-Time."
It certainly does feature
an autistic boy who
is very into math and science.
But I think it also shows him
in a very human light and a very
compassionate one.
And it shows how he's
really able to find,
I guess, independence,
in spite of all
of the challenges he faces.
ENRICO BIANCO: Indeed.
And I think it's actually
important to point out that
this meme that, say, autistics
are sort of hyperintelligent
in one particular field or
endeavour can sometimes be
a little bit damaging.
Because we're not all savants.
GEORGIA LYON: No,
we really aren't.
ENRICO BIANCO: We really aren't.
And so it can feel
kind of bad to have
your value as a person
defined by whether you have
this incredibly unique
and highly developed
talent, like as if,
for some reason,
maybe you are not so
valuable unless you have
savant-level talent
with numbers,
like Dustin Hoffman's
character in "Rain Man."
Yeah, I caught you there.
And so I think it's important
that we add all of our stories
to this tapestry of
understanding about autism.
So that was definitely
a very good question.
Thank you for asking it, the
gentleman back there who did.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for sharing your experiences.
I was wondering, going
back a little bit
to the beginning
of the talk, you
mentioned how finding a
label to describe yourself
was useful in some ways.
But you've been very ambiguous
about your relationship
to labels in general
throughout this entire talk.
Could you just comment
a little bit more
on, like, the putting
people into bins
of autism on the spectrum,
neurotypical, et cetera,
and how that affects the
way you view the world?
GEORGIA LYON: Yeah.
Well, I can say personally
what the label means to me.
Like, personally,
I have no trouble
with the label with autism
when referring to myself.
But I think in terms of just
labels in the wider world,
I think they're somewhat flawed
in many ways, I will say.
Because as you were
talking about, you know,
we have labels such as
neurotypical, autism, autism
spectrum.
But those labels are,
I guess, often applied
in a very precise
way that actually
doesn't help a lot of people.
For example, I
know that, in order
to be diagnosed with autism,
basically what they do
is they give you a test.
And if you get a score
above a certain number,
you have autism.
If it's below the
number, you don't.
Now, obviously, that
can be challenging.
Because let's say you
need a score of, like, 20.
Well, if you're a
19, you're probably
going to be facing a lot
of the same challenges
as a person who is, quote
unquote, "on the autism
spectrum."
But you wouldn't be able
to get the same help
and support as them.
And you wouldn't be able
to really explain it
in the same way to people.
And so, I think,
in that way labels
are very kind of limiting.
I think the reality is that even
though we use the term autism
spectrum, it really is just
a spectrum of human brains
and that the autism
spectrum is part of that.
But it flows into the
spectrum of what's
considered, quote
unquote, "normal,"
as well, and that there isn't
necessarily one great way
to define what autism is,
where it starts, where it ends,
what is high-functioning
autism, what
isn't high-functioning autism,
what's just normal, someone
maybe just being an introvert.
So I think my relationship
with labels in general
is not as positive as it is when
just using labels for myself.
AUDIENCE: I want to get
back to the question
that the gentleman back
here asked about products.
Because you and I
have a relationship.
And you may not
remember how difficult
it was for you to access
online information when
you were younger and that
you had a lot of help.
But not everybody has that help.
I mean, I know that it was very
visually confusing for you,
knowing where to click
and where not to.
So thinking about
it from that aspect,
do you have any different
answer about what
products might have been?
GEORGIA LYON: I mean,
I just don't know.
I mean, yeah, I
don't know, honestly.
That's the honest answer.
ENRICO BIANCO: I guess it
might be hard to remember.
GEORGIA LYON: Yes, it's
hard to remember sometimes.
ENRICO BIANCO: For me, my
mother gave me a computer
really early on.
And that was something, where
I just explored on my own.
And I learned by myself.
And so my mother was very
sort of hands-off about that.
She definitely worked
to give me the tool.
Like, I actually remember, she
built a computer from parts.
And she learned how to
do this, because she
wanted to be able to do this
for me, which was really
super awesome of her.
But when it came to, like,
exploring the World Wide Web--
and back then, we had
bulletin board systems
and so on-- she generally just
set me off and supported me
when things went
maybe less than good
but was otherwise willing to
let go and just let me explore.
And I think that
was really useful.
AUDIENCE: And I think that
goes back to the diversity.
Many of the children that I
work with are exactly like that.
ENRICO BIANCO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They could be on
there exploring all day.
But some people don't
come to it naturally.
GEORGIA LYON: Like me.
ENRICO BIANCO: I'm
sure that's true, yeah.
They always say that if you've
met one autistic person,
you've met--
[IN UNISON] one autistic person.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Exactly.
ENRICO BIANCO: And so,
with that, we'll close.
And I want to thank,
again, everybody
for attending here in person
and watching the live stream.
We will have a recording
available later.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]